I watch other people with their kids and
I thought if they could do it I could do
it you know that's what that's what
calmed me down a little bit yes I saw
this complete animal in the uh grocery
store just walking with this kid like he
had him like thrown over his shoulder
like a beach towel and he was trying to
find where his wife was and he just
looked like such a [ __ ] I remember just
thinking if this guy can keep that alive
I can't explain
the vacant look on this guy
I almost burst it out laughing when I
looked at him it's like you're a dad all
right what do you think of parents now
how do you compare them to parents in
the 70s oh it's just completely the kids
have so much power it's like ridiculous
like half of these kids I'm like I look
and I just have what happened to me and
I'm like looking at a kid and be like
this kid's about ready to get punted
across the grocery store and it just
never happens right they just
they just don't get hit and I think it's
hurting wait a minute
[Applause]
you're mad that children are not being
uh this should be the threat of it
half of it was just the book it was just
your dad was acting like he was going to
do it he never did it but your mother
did and because
because she was still because she was a
woman it was like okay because she was
like hey yo you let a girl beat you up
you know you kind of felt a masculated f
is for family oh yes season two
edgy for a comedy show free uh animated
show do you try to base it in reality
it's Loosely based on my childhood and I
had a very volatile
father you know love the guy to death
but he definitely could have brought the
volume down a little bit sometimes but
um you know he's in his underwear a lot
and I think a lot of people can relate
to that yeah I think but if you make it
a real person and they're screaming at
real kids people get nervous so but if
you draw them people don't care about
animated kids so
[Laughter]
[Applause]
after I look at from when I was a kid
that actually kind of made sense in a
way is now would now be considered like
abuse I guess like when I was a kid if
you didn't finish your supper as we
called it supper yeah my mother was just
like well you're gonna finish she would
just wrap it in cellophane and you just
picked up where you left off for
breakfast like like a blue collar job
like you could take the shovel out of
the hole and just start digging it again
so we were having cube steaks and I
figured my little brother was still in a
high chair and he couldn't finish his so
my mother goes all right we're just
gonna feed it for breakfast and that was
like eight hours away which was like
half his life so he's like I'll take
that deal
so the next morning we I remember we
were having waffles my mother always
made Sunday breakfast so we had all
these waffles eggs bacon this whole
layout my brother was looking at half
eaten cube steaks and a little mound of
green bean casserole and it goes so he
looked at my mom and goes mom can I have
a waffle
she goes no you got to finish your
supper he's like well after I finish my
walk supper then can I have a waffle she
goes no that is your breakfast and he
goes oh Mom I hate you and my dad
without looking up took a full glass of
milk and threw in his face
Andy and I have been through this uh not
together but uh we each have two kids
but you are now going through this
amazing life experience how's it going
what's your first time it's been going
it's not as hard as people say
uh you know people always [ __ ] more and
complaining but like I had enough
training before I got into this like
I've boozed hard until like four in the
morning and had to get up at eight like
my whole life go unload trucks go do a
gig or something like that so I'm kind
of used to it so you're used to this no
sleep thing you've done this before you
know yeah all right I catch flights and
just you know stumbling through the
airport going to the your seat
assignment rather than the gate and then
having to switch it up so yeah I've been
through it yeah so uh I can't believe
you think those are the same but all
right parents are the worst they're
crazy people I mean other people with
kids yeah yeah parents yeah people with
kids yeah I'm with you now okay I'm
sorry I was boozing till four in the
morning and then I went to the airport
so I'm a little out of it so uh so what
are they what are they driving you crazy
what are you talking about because all
they did was just bring anxiety like I
thought it was gonna be this great thing
to have a kid and to tell other people
and there's oh yeah I'm a kid oh wait
you know no more doing this no more
doing that you know just making it seem
like it was going to be this miserable
experience and uh it's been I mean I'm
only 10 days in but it's it's
a car out or anything yet it's been all
right what's the best thing so far in
your opinion about being a being a dad
I actually like going to the park with
my daughter pushing her on the swing and
all that and then also at her first
birthday party I realized how lucky I
was to have a girl because they just
sort of chill out and take things in and
I saw the little boys they're like
maniacs they're like throwing stuff
ripping like literally watching my
daughter she just kind of waves high at
everybody and the boys would come up
just rip toys out of her hands it was
like breaking my heart because she's it
she's you know she's so innocent she
hasn't met an [ __ ] yet so like it's
sort of like this oh what was that Vibe
and then the boys you know that climbing
on they're throwing rocks down on the
car it was like Braveheart every time I
told him it's like you guys you got to
stop doing this
and then also you can't you can't tell
other people's kids not to do stuff
right so you got to kind of like be
loudly like hey he's climbing up on the
utility pole and kind of
something we're back in the day you
could yell at people's kids and I think
that that needs to come back and that's
what's holding back this country yeah
get off hey I said don't do that and
then you got to be like hey look you
little [ __ ] you know that's my car yeah
stop throwing rocks on it yeah yeah
before I throw you over the wall you're
not gonna do it but you scare them a
little bit as a dad do you feel that you
uh have more or less importance than you
used to have when you were just a couple
with no children way less way less yes
that's been my experience as well yeah
like when you're dating just you feel
like you're number one then the second
you get like engaged you you become the
backup quarterback like you start going
down the depth chart and once you have a
kid I think I'm like fifth now like it
goes my daughter then my wife my
mother-in-law like the UPS driver
brings the Amazon stuff but I don't mind
because I'm like anti-social always you
know like I had the best Christmas I've
ever had since you know I was a little
kid and believed in Santa Claus just
coming back with a kid is then you don't
have to really engage with adults
anymore which is awesome you just come
in they're like hey Bill you're like hey
here's she is and they're like oh my God
and they all gravitate over you can go
hit the bar hang up nobody's talking to
you it's tremendous seems like you've
calmed down I know you had your second
child recently fatherhood comment right
now fatherhood made me have to figure
myself out
because I didn't want my kids to go
through you know some of the stuff that
I went through not saying it was all bad
but some of the stuff that I went
through so
um I just kept trying and failing with
the temper
and I ended up taking mushrooms
you took mushrooms to help you with your
temper then after that I was sort of
left with this uh profound sense of
loneliness and not feeling loved right
so I'm literally laying there
going what the hell is this I love my
wife and I love my kids and I figured it
out I go oh this is how I felt growing
up I get it and then I I was like I need
I've been running from this this feeling
that's why hey I I do stand up I fly
helicopters am I cool do you like me
it's funny now I haven't like flipped
out or yelled in my house
and uh but now I'm going up I still have
that need to be liked so now I'm like
going up to my wife like you know I
haven't yelled in a while have you
noticed yeah am I a swell guy do
you guys crushing need to be like I'm
really glad that since you had a child
you got over your anger issues
I look forward to a lifetime of you not
losing your courage
so soon in front of your typical parrot
can I just don't know doing coke I'm not
gonna be